i wasn't expecting black butler there
for some reason actually
i thought you were more of a fan of the
anime i didn't realize you wrote the
manga of that yeah i've read what
chapter i read up to i've read a good
chunk of black butler i haven't caught
up because i know that a bunch of [ __ ]
happened and there's a lot of big plot
twists that i know about but i haven't
read yet right but i've read most of
black butler and it's so so much better
in manga format than anime because the
first yeah really the first okay the
first season is basically like kind of
like a
i don't know episodical slice of life
kind of thing that doesn't really
progress the story that much yeah and
the second season is just non-canonical
right of black butler
saw that sorry
she fell down i just tripped on myself
again
montage of me not being able to drink
liquids it's a shame right because it's
the whole meme right right i kind of i
already talked about it because i don't
want to be you know people kind of want
to be like oh he's the black butler guy
but yeah i don't like i don't talk about
it now um but yeah the third season of
black butler the anime is based on like
the manga and it's amazing like it's
like a really morbid part it's really
dark and you kind of realize how good it
can be yeah um but yeah the manga is a
really really good good read and i'd
recommend it if you kind of like the
idea of black butler but don't want to
go through with the anime yeah and i
wouldn't have read it if it wasn't for
my youtube videos yeah because like i've
heard the second season of black butler
is that different from the manga yeah
that's what it hurts
[Music]
it's universally like hated okay um but
like genuinely give the manga a shot
it's it's pretty good so what's like
different about the manga than the anime
that would you would recommend the manga
over it
well follow it's like way more serious
way more like it doesn't like [ __ ]
around and it doesn't really feel like
because the anime very much feels like
it's kind of just yowie bait at times
yeah
it's definitely generally pertained to
its audience yeah and it's very and the
first season again it's very casual it
doesn't really
it
it does it does cover a lot of the same
things but it does it in a way that i
just i think okay i watched season one
of the anime and i thought it was like
it's fun it's fun but the the manga does
it so much better there's so much more
justice and i feel like like art style
is a lot just like more gritty and like
kind of different it's so good she gets
better as well and it's so good and the
third seed of black butler covers like a
circus arc yeah and it's so good and the
anime does it justice
[ __ ] of circles
yeah so it's like the anime finish now
or is the manga finish sorry i think the
man is still going the mine is still
ongoing oh it's still going it's still
going it's quite long running and um i
don't know how many volumes are on i
think we're over like 13 at this point i
think it's way more quite a lot i think
it's like over 20 now is it really over
25. i think i've already read up to like
10. all right but i really enjoyed it i
wanted i don't know why i stopped i'd
probably go and read it because you know
when you catch up to a certain point
you're like okay i'm done yeah before i
know that for me for me like my my manga
reading habits is that i just love binge
reading math yeah so much i can't
30 of black butler i know i've read over
half i think right but i don't know how
long ago that was because i think what
was happening is that i got really burnt
out on it because i read so much of it
in like facebook and your entire career
was yes
yeah then that happened then i got which
but i think this is probably going to
remind me to get back into it
because with one punch when i did that
as well which we'll talk about later
yeah but genuinely i think even though
if you've seen the show i would give it
a shot yeah i've definitely i i did
remember giving the black butler manga a
go like after i finished watching season
one yeah because i just at that point
season two had already finished airing
and i just heard yeah don't watch season
two yeah so i was like all right time
for the manga then and i just never got
to it yeah and there's some it's
really really dark at times like you
forget like the main premise is that in
black butler he hits a demon and then
he's made a contract with him yeah to
have his life at the end yeah yeah and
like they kind of play off it a lot in
the anime and make it seem like oh it's
kind of hot huh it's kind of
okay you know but uh yeah in the manga
they constantly remind you sometimes
like oh [ __ ] he just like murders people
like they're straight up and they're not
afraid of like showing like really
morbid stuff there's some really good
plot twists you know like i won't spoil
some of them but there's some really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that happens in there
right and it's really worth giving it a
shot even though all the stereo not
stereotypes but the all the uh what's
the word
facade i guess facade or the
preconceptions that a lot of the western
anime fans have i think in japan it's
pretty [ __ ] popular i think oh yes
but it's popular but it definitely does
have like a strong female audience yeah
i mean sebastian is iconic yeah i mean
being the sexy man
i mean he was like the sexy man of anime
for like the early two the early to mid
2000's i still argue if you make a list
of top five sexiest anime characters
sebastian's on like yeah he is just sexy
he just has that like
[Music]
it's black butler in it like he's just
he's just an icon of his time for like
anime and manga at the time like for
like there's there's a few like i'd say
characters in like anime that just
personified a certain character trait
like do you think of yandere for our
generation he's [ __ ] you know right
right you know i mean you think sexy man
it's sebastian from black bottle yeah i
don't think anyone's replaced him yet
yeah no i mean the one that got close
was maybe like yuri from uranus yeah but
even then even then
yeah yeah i don't think he's just i
don't think he's just charming
is just a staple of like it's like the
sexy butler yeah of and but also just
very suave very charismatic yeah like
it's very entertaining and i feel like
sebastian does carry a lot of the time
because he's just so fun and even though
he is like obedient he's just he makes
it so entertaining yeah and and you know
again and even my videos i didn't didn't
even remotely do him justice he's such
he's so witty and so clever in the anime
and the manga sorry it's it's so he's so
fun to watch
and the uh you know the third season of
the anime is good and the uh book of
murder i think it's called is that
correct book of murder is pretty fun
it's like kind of like a mini whodunit
right within like in like two hours it's
pretty fun that's cool yeah and it's uh
obviously sebastian solves everything
and does it magically which is always
fun because it's like
because it's like what if sakamoto
became a butler later on in life
that that is effective i feel like
sebastian and sakamoto are just like
they're weird yeah they're separated at
birth you know what i mean they're
literally the same person like
sakamoto is just sebastian in school
yeah
because they literally have the same
kind of like it's maybe maybe sakamoto
is a little more uh tongue-in-cheek yeah
but sebastian very much has the same
kind of uh visual humor a lot of the
time and does like a lot of
you know he's the joke is often that he
is just so insanely competent at
everything just
but it's amazing like it's so good i
just love it it's so and it's i feel
like there's this not a manga that that
has the same feeling as black butler
like i don't think there's a single
manga that feels like it or anime show
that has the same kind of vibe yeah yeah
i feel it definitely like created a
staple for that
genre like there's probably a lot of
manga that's imitating black butler 100
percent hundreds yeah because there's
not many manga out there that do like
deal with like pretty intense themes
they have like
all these like thriller aspects they
also have the the you know the parts
that appeal to the fujo is quite a lot
yeah right so it kind of mixes a lot of
genres together and i think even jana
tobaso herself said that she didn't even
know what genre she'd put it in
because it's so it touches on so many
genres throughout the manga yeah that's
why i think it's super unique and worth
worth reading okay did you watch the
anime or read the manga first anime
first okay i should i should have
expected that actually yeah so anime i
got into so i watched the anime yeah and
you know i thought wow
i just watched it and i thought it was
kind of man it's kind of boring
i thought it was okay you know i thought
season two was god-awful yeah and at
this time book of six hadn't came out
yet and uh basically i i did that and
then someone was oh you should uh you
should just do like character
impressions for my youtube channel yeah
well okay i did a few and then sebastian
just happened to be the one that i tried
first and i thought it sounded nothing
like him
uh
i'm sure he was offended that people
were i'd be offended
um and then i did that and then i got
you know i got surrounded by people who
loved it and he kept like telling me
read it really read it yeah i was like
reluctant i was like no so wait what
what was the first manga you ever read
first is it on the three by the way um
[Music]
that you like distinctly remember it
might have been black but no it must
have been black butler yeah
it's black butler and i didn't read any
for like two years right
he just thought manga equals black male
1 because
the reason why i actually got into it i
remember this now because i did a manga
dub of uh part of the uh the uh
the boat arcs called uh the campaign
york companion just the boat off the
whitetalk the book of atlantic is it
the book of atlantic i think we called
it because they made a movie about it i
haven't watched the movie um i did a
comic dub of a portion of that and so uh
yeah i just ended up reading it because
i was like oh this uncle looks cool and
i had it out of context and i was like
oh
okay uh well this is cool i'm gonna go
read the rest and i started reading it
and i read past that point and then i
stopped right but everything before i
enjoyed but i'm probably gonna go finish
it yeah because what i want to know is
that i'm looking at most of these and
i'd say a lot of these have come from
recommendations literally from us
telling you like go out and read it i
know exactly which one's got recommended
i know which ones i recommend